I saw this video yesterday this is
absolutely mind-blowing so this is from
Columbia University this is Columbia
University Medical students chanting
about critical race Theory and a whole
bunch more listen to the tone the tenor
of all of this the repetitiveness the
droning of these clones I mean this is
absolutely wild enjoy we enter the
profession of Medicine with appreciation
for the opportunity to build on the
scientific and humanistic achievements
of the past we also recognize the acts
and systems of Oppression affected in
the name of medicine we take the source
of service to begin building a future
grounded in truth restoration and Equity
to fulfill medicine's capacity to
liberate I promise to take care of my
future patients by engaging in dialogue
listening to their lived experience and
tailoring my recommendations to their
unique circumstances
I acknowledge the past and present
failures of medicine to abide by its
obligation to do no harm and affirm the
need to address systemic issues in the
institutions I uphold I promise to
critically examine the systems and
experiences that impact every person's
health and ability to receive care I vow
to use this knowledge to uplift my
patience and disrupt the injustices that
harm them as I Forge the future of
Medicine
I promise to self-reflect diligently to
confront unconscious prejudices and to
develop the skills knowledge and
character necessary to engender an
inclusive Equitable field of Medicine
and then they all drank the Kool-Aid and
drop dead
um Rob I I mean I started scribbling
down some of the things wrong that we
heard there but how about just the
general tone of that the the the
lifeless tone with which the woman reads
that they read these are supposed to be
really bright young people who are going
to save lives Equitable medicine sounds
like you're gonna have to kill a certain
set of people I think Heather was
basically alluding to that
yeah Dave that does look like a like a
pseudo-religious service I mean I looked
like a ceremony these people are taking
part in you know reminds me of like you
know being little and watching like like
little kids at church having to like
repeat something that they don't want
they don't want to be there they're kind
of bored it's like these people I don't
know how many of them actually believe
what they're saying but the fact that
they're being instructed to do these
things when that's not really their role
to examine unconscious biases
institutional corruption racism I mean
if you ask any doctor they're overloaded
with so much work to do I mean so much
overwhelming data and you know do I
recommend a drug here or a behavioral
intervention or whether it's exercise or
sleep or medication or do this test or
that test and now they're also being
told to reflect on institutional bias
like it's completely out of their
purview and I don't know why they would
start recommending doctors to do this
kind of thing
if you'd like more sane takes on our
insane World check out our direct
message clips playlist and if you want
to watch more full episodes of our live
round tables watch our round tables
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell